welcome to the golden hour where the
ugly look beautiful and the Beautiful
look like everyone else it's over for
you all once we finish animating Brock
Purdy oh little old me in a photo sure I
guess I'll stop it you're eight and four
where are the Titans we're behind
Brian's head Brian Lamar's out for a few
steps oh wait I'm getting a tweet alert
STFU y'all be cat okay this is very
problematic cut to commercial we don't
do that make an exception
let's go to a quad box to check in on
all four NFC east teams yelling
cheesesteaks [ __ ]
great photos always get me in trouble
that monster on the Browns is back
[Music]
Make Way for Mike White the King of New
York hi hello
oh man up top Justin Herbert has entered
the picture while Cheeto Smith is also
making a move timely if the brakes have
been like really bad lately okay we're
losing light smile well at least the AFC
looks nice
oh no where is everyone what's going on
calm down Kirk it's just night time
where the Cowboys time
that's scary
scary